scp-1730 is one of the biggest threats
the foundation has ever faced
scp-1730 does not exist
it was june 5th when the compound was
first discovered a large complex of
structures in rural texas
about 15 kilometers northwest of the
mexican border located in big bend ranch
state park
it was easily the biggest structure in
the area but there was no record of any
such structure
ever being built a massive network of
power stations containment facilities
and research buildings scp-1730 looked
like it had been abandoned for a long
time
the exterior was degraded but the
building was still operating
a power generator had been running for
an indeterminate amount of time
even as the infrastructure degraded
power flickered through the site
and fuel leaked frequently but there was
one detail that attracted the attention
of scp brass
scp-1730 bore identifying markings
linking it to foundation
site 13 a research facility that was
marked for construction
near gnome alaska but site 13 had never
been built
having been abandoned in the planning
stages so why is it in the middle of
texas fully constructed
and long abandoned the foundation needed
to know more
and they needed their best to
investigate it was time to call in the
game wardens
apollo 3 the mobile task force used to
investigate dangerous sites was brought
in
and five elite agents were briefed and
sent in ross
houston noah o'hallo and vigo it didn't
take long for them to discover that
something was very wrong with the site
of scp-1730
the facility was located in the middle
of south texas but
the local flora surrounding it was
native to nome alaska
something had transported a building
that shouldn't exist to another place
and time
commander ross ordered his men to enter
with houston taking the lead
they discovered that the entry led down
a long staircase
they descended slowly following a
strange light that no one could identify
but had a sudden shock when they
discovered that the basement of the
staircase was missing
the light suddenly stopped and it became
so dark that it was impossible to see
what lay beyond the staircase
upon probing the inky black void at the
base of the staircase
they determined it wasn't a fog or
shadow it was a liquid
and it was rising ross ordered the men
to pull back but houston was in too deep
he couldn't break free from the inky
black liquid the men pulled him away and
got him free but his legs
were gone not ripped off because there
was no blood anywhere
smoothly cut off as if they were never
there and as they put houston down he
stood up on
phantom legs he didn't feel any pain but
everyone could tell
something was very wrong with this place
and the messages they
started seeing on the wall made clear
they weren't the only ones who knew it
what happened to site 13 death here not
my body
bleed there had been other people or
things inside scp-1730
and they wanted anyone who entered to
know that this was a very dangerous
place to be
as they advanced down the hall back
toward the entrance they saw it looked
like a person in the distance
but as they approached it became clear
it wasn't another explorer
it was an old horribly disfigured corpse
seemingly attached to the wall
not by chains but fused to the wall in
unnatural ways
at first the team seemed unconcerned
recognizing the corpse as someone named
zachary
fortunately command back at the base
realized this as the effects of some
sort of
cognito hazard a mental infection in the
base
they uploaded a filter to their helmets
and the team recoiled in horror
at the site in front of them but the
horrors were just beginning
they turned around to see a shimmering
humanoid entity in the hallway behind
him
as it approached its footsteps distorted
the hallway around
it pulled ap-3 noah toward it without
touching him
and as the soldier was pulled into its
clutches his body started to distort
viggo was next being grabbed by the arm
by a long appendage and his arm started
to change color and distort
but the foundation sent apollo 3 and
prepared houston produced a portable
reality anchor
designed to handle reality warping
entities and with a flash of red light
the creature was revealed
it was a horribly elongated humanoid
that only existed for a second before
the reality anchor erased it
and restored the hallway to its normal
state vigo would recover with the
strange red color in his arm fitting
eventually
noah wasn't so lucky he was already dead
had been fused into the wall just like
the unfortunate corpse
these horrors had been encountered just
by trying to return to the entrance
so it was clear the only smart thing to
do was to descend
further into the facilities and get some
answers as they advanced
not encountering any other supernatural
entities they saw more evidence of the
dark things that had occurred in site-13
the infirmary had been torn apart a
cafeteria had been melted into slag
and a large group of containment cells
ended with a section called
olympia class but while most of the
other cells were standard sized
these were over 100 meters high what had
the foundation
or whoever ran this place been keeping
in these cells
they would get more answers as they made
their way down the hall where they saw a
single television still working
and illuminating the hallway at first
the television flickered but the image
soon cleared
and the agents were able to see what it
was broadcasting it was the interior of
a containment cell
and there was someone in it and they
recognized them as one of the most
dangerous beings contained by the scp
foundation
bobble the clown a predatory
supernatural clown
that inhabits a children's tv show
bobble the clown was broadcast by an
unknown source and could only be seen by
children under 10
originally seeming to be a normal kids
show about a clown
every episode eventually devolved into
the murderous bauble teaching kids how
to do horrible things
like arson and torture the foundation
eventually captured an isolated bobble's
broadcast but the clown remained hostile
and vicious
but not here as the team talked to the
bobble trapped in the mysterious site 13
it became clear that this clown was
broken by whatever it had experienced it
rambled and hid from the camera and it
was clearly terrified as it told the
team about the horrors of the site
and it seemed to recognize the agents as
something familiar
but not completely familiar it claimed
to be able to smell them
and it said they smelled different as
bauble rambled on the agents learned
about a man named emerson
who ran the site like the foundation he
was obsessed with containing the strange
and dangerous entities in the world
but unlike the foundation he didn't just
want to protect the world from them
he hated them the entities in site 13
didn't even have numbers
emerson wanted to use them up however he
wanted and to dispose of them
and something bobble called the meat
grinder entities that outlived their
usefulness were taken down below and
none were ever heard from again
it was directly counter to every scp
foundation policy
but this site had clearly been
performing these horrible experiments
for years
how and why hadn't anyone heard of it
the team continued to make their way
into the facility but their signals were
lost as they entered the cryogenics unit
by the time contact had been restored
they were no longer alone
there were survivors both agents of the
foundation
and survivors of the facility and they
were angry with no way out and massively
outnumbered
they called for backup mobile task force
t5
also known as samsara was reserved for
the heavy duty missions
they're an elite group of practically
immortal cyborgs fashioned from the
flesh of a god
and equipped with further cybernetic
enhancements to eliminate keter level
threats
and protect themselves from cognito
hazards they were sent in through a
drainage gate to look for survivors and
neutralize whatever lay within
they didn't know what to expect but they
knew one thing no one who had been sent
in had come
out it wasn't long before they realized
how dangerous this mission would be
as they came across some large gated
drainage pipes they could see at least
20 charred bodies of humanoids pushed up
against the gate
some reaching their hands through
whatever had happened in site 13
these unfortunate beings had been
desperate to escape
as they made their way down the drainage
pipe they could feel it getting hotter
as if they were nearing an energy source
there was one other odd thing about the
pipe
it was draining inward not out they made
their way into a control room where many
of the consoles had been destroyed
looking through a window their view was
obscured by a mysterious black mass
on the control panels they could read
terms like incinerator
and body pit access they split up trying
to find answers but found many of their
accesses blocked by the black mass
as the t5 task force argued over their
next move they were startled by a sudden
jolt
the giant mass had started moving the
team watched as the mass spun
revealing a giant turbine which turned
the inky substance into a fine slurry
that was then scorched by giant streaks
of fire
one of the t5 shot open the glass
chamber allowing the team to be closer
and blasting them with a wave of heat as
they descended into the chamber
they could see a massive plant-like
structure overhead which started to
shake
suddenly thousands of glowing pods were
released from the massive plant
and each one lit up and let the team
view the chamber more clearly
but it was what was inside the pods that
was more disturbing
each pod had a humanoid shape inside
seemingly reaching toward the team
until they hit the slurry below and the
shadows went dark the team descended to
investigate the slurry
when something started to leak out of
the walls looking at it they could see
something moving within
one of the team members picked up the
wriggling object out of the black liquid
and it took a bite of his hand it was a
leech and there were thousands more of
them moving toward the slurry consuming
it
and as the leeches ate they started
growing they seemed to be moving in
unison communicating with a larger being
lurking at the base of the slurry a
larger leech a queen
or something else the team wasn't
sticking around to find out
they beat a hurried escape from the
leech room finding themselves in another
hallway
whatever the black substance was the
entities who had been here had used it
scrolling blood on the walls over and
over again occasionally they would come
across a drained corpse covered in the
black fluid had the leeches bled them
dry
the facility was so sprawling that the
team knew if they wanted any chance of
navigating it safely they needed to get
the lay of the land
they needed to find the control center
the door read stairs to cryonics and the
leeches were nowhere to be found
it seemed like a safe path but as soon
as the team entered the temperature
dropped drastically
to well below where it would be safe for
a human to survive the team's internal
heating system kicked in to save their
lives but it wasn't the only threat
the team was about to encounter exactly
what site 13 was keeping locked up
as soon as they entered the room sound
ceased to work
the filters in their gear were
overloaded and the team saw warnings
around the room
silence don't look a massive
multi-limbed figure emerged with each of
its 60 arms moving independently
the creature had no head but a large
circular structure covered with ancient
glowing symbols
whatever it was it was ancient
all-powerful and
deadly the team scrambled to get away as
the glyphs on the creature burned white
hot
anyone who touched it was burned anyone
who looked too long at it
felt their optical implants burn out the
symbols on the creature were
indecipherable
but one word was clear and printed in
english emerson
site 13 was from another world another
timeline where the scp foundation
evolved into something horrible
ruled over by elliot emerson it tortured
and captured its beings
and eventually killed most of them in
the horrors of the incinerators
when an escape threatened to destroy the
facility emerson successfully activated
the device
that removed the facility from their
world into ours of course as any avid
follower of the scp foundation will know
there's far
more to the story than this emerson may
have been the start of site 13's
problems but he was far from the end
we're talking about a tale so epic in
size and scope
that it would be impossible to fit into
one video
a tale of subterranean horror a daring
rescue mission into the bowels of site
13
and an anomalous battle to end all
battles and you can look forward to that
epic tale including the horrifying story
of leech boy in the tragic saga of dr
hadley in part two
the samsara extraction mission trust us
it's worth waiting up for